president biden goes to baltimore today
to promote the benefits of a giant new
infrastructure package approved by
congress now it promises tens of
billions of dollars to repair america's
bridges and airports and build new
railways and expand broadband access
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on this nancy good morning to you
the president has got a lot to sell
that's right and this bill keep in mind
gail has not even been signed yet but
we're already learning a lot more about
where this one trillion dollars is going
to go as states identify the
infrastructure projects in their
districts that are most in need of cash
first up to get fixed in south carolina
is the so-called malfunction junction a
tangle of highways outside columbia in
kentucky it's the brent spence bridge a
notorious choke point for freight trucks
that routinely sheds chunks of concrete
into the ohio river below
that state alone is slated to get at
least 4.6 billion dollars it's a godsend
for kentucky i voted for it i'm proud of
it new york's metropolitan
transportation authority will get a 10
billion dollar cash infusion after
ridership plummeted more than 90 percent
at the beginning of the pandemic
and in benton harbor michigan this week
crews began an 18-month project to
replace all lead service water lines
with copper ones in anticipation of the
1.3 billion dollars the state will get
for water system improvements it's
exciting to see that this can be done
one day every state will get at least
100 million dollars to expand broadband
access states with large underserved
rural areas will get millions more but
identifying the right projects and
planning them takes time as the commerce
secretary cautioned on tuesday it's
important to be realistic you have to be
honest with people which is to say we
want to get this right you know it's
more important to get it right than to
rush
president biden is going to be visiting
the port of baltimore this afternoon to
highlight the roughly 17 billion dollars
that's going to be going towards
renovating the nation's ports and
strengthening the supply chain which is
something that is on so many americans
minds right now as they wonder gail
whether their holiday gifts are going to
arrive on time
i know we all want the answer to that
nancy before you go we're learning a
very disturbing threats that have been
made against the republican lawmakers
who supported that infrastructure bill
i've heard some of the calls it's really
really disturbing what can you tell us
about that
right you know this bill got a lot of
republican support in the senate but in
the house only 13 republicans voted yes
and they're now getting a lot of abuse
for instance congressman fred upton of
michigan who you just heard from in our
piece he played for us a voicemail that
his office received take a listen
you're a [ __ ] piece of trader i hope
you die
i hope everybody in your [ __ ] family
dies hope everybody your [ __ ] staff
dies traitor
representative of the really disturbing
stuff that is now heading these
lawmakers way president trump has been
very hard on them as well he wrote in a
statement that those who voted with
democrats for this bill should be
ashamed of themselves earlier this year
it's worth pointing out u.s capitol
police said that risks for lawmakers
remain at an all-time high they say that
close to 9 000 threats are taking place
against members of congress this year
alone gail
that kind of anger is so upsetting nancy
thank you very much